[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
hi there i'm brian wood technical
communications and outreach manager here
at wolfram
uh joining me today is developer joffrey
espigool
how are you doing today how are you
thank you
good uh joffrey joffrey's going to talk
to us a little bit about
biodiversity data in the wolfram
language um
so i guess we can start with kind of a
quick summary
uh what exactly is it that you've been
doing what what kind of uh
data have you been collecting so as
a hobby i have uh been recording uh
species data mainly images also some
sound recordings
on on a variety of platforms
like there's one citizen scientist
platform called inactualist
and i was uploading several several
identifications of species there
and then i thought that it would be like
really cool to integrate this data
into warframe language so i started
developing uh
functions that would uh access to these
information from these platforms of
biodiversity
and be able to do some analysis on them
one is
the gvif it's the global biodiversity uh
information facility which is an
international organization
that many countries are are working with
and the other
natural is it's more a citizen scientist
platform
with over 1 million users that
just for fun they are they are recording
some some
uh images of different species
gotcha so when you say citizen scientist
i mean it's literally just anyone who's
out there
exactly you know watching or or you know
collecting bugs or anything like that
and then they just sort of add their
information to the database yeah
most of the users are are just hobbyists
or like citizen scientists
that they record uh some
animals on under hikes for example
and but that there are also like some
real real uh scientists or like
experts in in certain species that can
help you to identify
uh for example uh
kind of a real strange spider that you
don't know
about it and they they can help you so
and
i think it's it's both like citizen
scientists and scientists
working on this platform yeah yeah and
it kind of makes sense i think
uh for something as as large as
uh biology you know there could be just
any random person out in the woods that
comes across
a species that no one's ever seen and if
you didn't have that data then you
wouldn't know that no one had ever seen
that so
um so i know uh you've got a few
examples of some of the stuff that
you've collected and
some of what kind of what can be done
with this so why don't we why don't we
go ahead and dive into your notebook
here real quick
um let me share the screen so this is
the
notebook and i will start with maybe
high naturalist data
right this is a work from function
repository
function that you can all access now
using the resource function
and what it does i naturally search for
example is
that you can either ask for
a certain kind of
data set that for example on on
threatened species
on a geo region for example in this case
you can specify
with observation geo range that you want
observations located in in the
yellowstone national park
and also you can specify a date range
okay
the idea is that you can
um also in in this case i put all so i
want uh
all kind of observations but you can
also specify the the tax on
there and these are are all observations
from inauguralist users and
we can even check the the
observation url or the image
and that give us information on the
deposition and uh geoposition of the
observation and if it has some some
uh kind of warframe uh taxon entity
associated it's also there and there's
also this new function called wikidata
data
that kind of brings
this kind of kind of sort of entities
that are useful for getting extra
information
right so so you're actually not only
pulling in the information that's
already there
in the i naturalist database you're sort
of adding some of the wolfram knowledge
on top of that that
maybe you could use for supplementary
analysis kind of stuff
exactly so once it's interpreted uh
as an entity you are able to
also do all the sort of uh kind of
computations
on top of that species yeah
excellent so what is the example that
you've got here
for example this is an example on trying
to
identify uh kind of brown marmorated
testing bags
but classify whether they are adults or
kind of young youngsters like nymph
which is called in in
the art reports terminology
and the idea is that with this uh is
uh like a couple of lines of code
you can uh the species name is it's
heliomorpholis
and this is an in the impassive species
of bag that came
to us and also in europe from
japan and and asia in general
and now it's a it's a huge pla plague
and the idea is that um a natural this
uh
search has uh this property that you can
live stage and you can specify in which
life stage
do you want the observations to be
also here i was specifying uh kind of
research quality grade so
they are confirmed by other users that
this is
the case that it's a nymph
oh okay so now it sort of has its own
built-in measure for
uh for accuracy is that it's kind of how
that kind of
it's it's it's sometimes um
it's kind of it's really easy to to get
maybe
wrong research quality grid sure but
uh you are assuming that users are
honest because if two friends are
mutually
identifying the species as a particular
one
then it's going to be research great at
least two users
they have to agree that makes sense
and once that's uh that's the case uh
the natural state is also
i think every week or month it's sent
to the gbif facility
so the data that which is research grade
it's also used by other scientists in in
the gbif
the global biodiversity information
facility so actually using this kind of
free app or this platform financial is
you can really help
some some researchers indirectly
yeah yeah that's that's an interesting
interesting kind of workflow
going from the citizen scientists sort
of working its way up until
uh the all the experts are using it as
well
and in this case i i wanted to to do
like a toy example
uh using classify to create a classifier
on on
adults and nymph of um this
kind of impassive sting back
and here is like an example
kind of neem fire a big uh like
they look like blackish and
adults are a bit different
and it it was not perfect but it was
quite good identifying um yeah adults
and youngsters
it might be a good way to because
they're like i think um
many many thousand observations on steam
bags and not everyone is tagging them
as uh the stage life so that would be
like a way to
um help automotize uh the
kind of the big data set on steam bags i
think that there are
over 100 000 observations of this
particular steam steelback
that's a it's a pretty pretty decent
sized data set
um but like in theory you could do this
with
pretty much in that
that database and and just sort of get
similar results and
be able to to run this kind of workflow
um for just about anything uh that's uh
it seems pretty good exactly
i think i'm also almost so i'm going to
publish
from blog post on on monk butterflies
and there
i do this the same example but using uh
males and females of monarch it seems
that
the females have a different coloration
in the wings so
it's also easy to create a classifier
that works
fairly well and of course
any other idea could could be
implemented
so it's it's now it's you have a really
easy
data access to uh yeah
hundred thousand uh thousands of species
from everywhere in the world i think now
they reached uh over yeah i i don't
remember the exact numbers on how many
species they
they yeah another users uh
recollected but it's growing every week
by
thousands yeah all right so
uh what else what other data sources are
you looking at here
in actual search it has a limitation
on the number of um kind of observations
that every call
to the api can do so you need to do
multiple uh api calls so
i naturally import solve this issue
by being able to just
download from the website directly a c
csv
file and this csv file can contain
uh many thousand observations and once
you download it
into the same into your
locally you can then import it uh
import uh the data set directly using
inauguralist import
and and this will overcome the
limitations on on
observations that you might have and in
this case i i was
doing a kind of a two example on
different
u.s ticks also transmitting several
diseases
yeah that's uh you can see that's from
the number of uh data points there you
wouldn't want to uh
have to be rate limited at you know
pulling in however many at a time you
just want
the the thousands of uh data points that
you are looking for
so yeah
and i think uh maybe uh
i can maybe just live code these
i i need to to run that
but maybe oh yeah and and anyone who
isn't familiar with the
uh wolfram function repository uh it
works pretty much the same way
uh you can see he's got this resource
function
uh expression and that just
automatically
imports the function that he's asking
for uh which then
can be used directly in whatever wolf
from language code
you might be trying to evaluate
which is which is pretty convenient for
stuff like this because it's not
it's not something built into the
language permanently but
it's kind of a little addition that you
decided to
add on here like you said from your own
personal interest so
yes i think it
now it's just right let me see it work
yes so in this case the data set has
747 tick species
from us over the last i guess
or the last few years 12 years
and i think that they're like there are
many overlaps but you can clearly see
um kind of different distributions for
different tick species uh yeah this is
all
only kind of the the yellow one it's
living in california
also the that kind of dark green
and that there are like some i think
that this there must
maybe um i'm wrong here but the one of
these
it's transmitting the the lyme disease
in the east coast yeah
and also it's like how is it with both
languages to create like a histogram
on and apparently people are
are finding more observations of sticks
in in
during spring most of them
attach it to dogs or even people right
but
yeah and there is a
kind of a short in october as well i
think that's
that the two periods where the the ticks
are reproducing yeah yeah
next oh well and when the two periods
where people are
out probably outside the most we're uh
you know
they're more likely to run into them
exactly
all right so why don't we uh why don't
we go quickly through these the other
two uh
functions that you've got here or the
other two data sources i guess
so i think i mentioned earlier but a
global biodiversity information
facilities it's
it's one of the largest kind of
international infrastructure
or i think it's a collaboration between
different
uh governments around the world and and
kind of there are several universities
as well and
and it contains the largest data set on
biodiversity globally and it's not just
a citizen scientist
but it's also researchers and the idea
here was also to create a
gbi app search that works with a
gbif api and automatically
pulls kind of also like interprets um
some of the data and you can
um kind of specify the geo range for
example with geo bounds
i mean in this example for for example
i'm trying to
um create a plot or like a
geographics on on on the distribution of
different species
of um givens uh this
kind of monkeys that live in in borneo
island
and the idea is kind of it it works
similarly as as the tbi i naturally
search
function so
um just so these functions are probably
kind of designed to
to take the same kinds of arguments then
and and sort of work the same way but
just for these different data sets then
exactly they might work a bit
differently because the api
is it's different but uh my my intention
was to make a
kind of a coherent uh functionality
and and maybe in the future have just a
species data
and be able to to specify in which
database
and have a default one but that
makes sense and the same for gif import
this is for large uh data sets
containing uh
too many data points but in this case it
was just
uh saying that there is an embassy
in business kamali on in hawaii
it is nice uh tracing i think it's a
kind of riser and uh with three horns uh
coming in yeah i wouldn't have thought
of the uh chameleon
as an invasive species i never knew that
that's uh yeah but it kind of makes
sense
probably people brought them as pets or
something and
interesting and i think it's uh it it
was
funny to see that they're like uh in
this line of code i was testing
if there are more observations outside
uh kind of uh
hawaii or or or in how i did which is in
any pieces of species and it seems that
since there are more maybe
uh i naturally users in hawaii
and this side unnatural observations
that are research great are sent to gvif
uh yeah the the answer was that there
are more observations globally
from hawaii and from i think they are
from uh africa
yeah that's kind of an interesting
limitation that i wouldn't have thought
of like
it really depends on who's submitting
information from where
when you are doing some data analysis on
biodiversity you have to
to be careful on these kind of bias that
introduce observers
interesting and finally it's
uh i'm going to talk about the global
biotic interactions
uh it's it's a an open x
platform where the
there is a lot of information on on
on the interactions between species so
it's not just
uh observations here it's more about
what are the the relationships between
species if
uh for example in this example is the
great shark
all type of uh species that great great
white shark is eating
i'm not sure if you would be able to
find almost sapience
and one of the notes definitely there's
the
the mammals and seals
yeah i mean you would think you know it
does happen occasionally
so i haven't i haven't checked it but uh
i found
mammals in one of the branches because
this is a taxonomic graph
that i'm also creating alternatively all
you can also
specify that you want a data set of
of these um kind of interactions and in
in this case i was doing a bit more
advanced uh
of three different species uh two our
fish and the others the
river otter and and checking the common
species that they both eat of course the
river other
uh eats all of them but um
yeah the brook trout yeah it's also
eating uh
the the spread i don't know if it's my
pronunciation pronunciation of a spread
is
it's historic i don't know i think so i
i'm actually not sure that's a
fair question i don't think i've ever
heard of a spread
but that works with any species out
there
so the input can be
a war from a kind of entity species
entity
but it also you can introduce if it's
not available you can introduce the
as a string to specific species or taxon
and then as for um
yeah other type of interactions that
there's also some
maybe i can show the
the one i was doing for morag
butterflies
and there i was also able to
show them so yeah so i'm i'm kind of
curious about i
i have never i don't think i've ever
really seen a food web
in a computational context like that
uh so i i can imagine that with it being
a graph there are probably
different kinds of analytics that you
could do to it that people might not
have thought of
really applying to biology before i'm
curious if you've run into anything like
that that's sort of
a new way of looking at things not yet
but
i think that there is a lot of potential
of exploring
in a graph way the interactions maybe
using some of the kind of framework
developed during the top often physics
project
with the multi-way systems and and graph
networks
probably there's uh room for him for
searching some some
interesting results but uh as i was
mentioning uh
you can for example specify uh
para parcel palestite interactions
so there is the possibility of
asking for example
also in this case milkweed is one of the
plants that uh
monarch butterflies are feeding from
and gadgets they guess that you can also
have the reverse network
specifying which organisms or species
eat
that plant and i think that there's
a bunch of different um
interactions the list is um
yeah i think maybe
i don't know if i should go to the
website of global data and check all
all the possible interactions
like in this case yeah here here there
is like a
parasite kind of
taxonomic in the network on on the
monarch butterfly
and in this case i think that there were
like different type of
viruses oh yeah okay and there's
one specific to some
that are unclassified and this one is
a type of virus that is only
kind of specific to a variety of
butterfly
interesting so this is sort of uh a lot
of this stuff is kind of at the edge of
of what we know it seems like where it's
yeah it's it's
in most cases it's not
final it's it's evolving it's growing
but i think uh
it it's it's good to to have a
kind of a place to start uh feeding and
this interaction sometimes
uh are are kind of
there because of some citizen scientists
uh
observed uh certain species eating
certain other species that was not
known by science so
when you're recording some observation
via a photo
of a species eating another species you
can specified interaction
between the two species and if it's uh
the first one that
was observing that interaction it's
gonna be also
at some point to that kind of network
yeah that's and i can imagine that's a
that's a very specialized kind of
observation that you you just happen to
see oh hey
that thing is eating that other thing
yes um so yeah it's it's uh
almost just interesting to think of the
variety of ways that this is being
collected you know
and it's it's pretty easy to to have
some uh
first time ever in science uh
observation
you just need to kind of open your eyes
and
and record photos put in the into the
platform and sometimes
some expert in the field uh some
entomologist or
technologist will tell you oh this is
this is novel
i i've never seen this spider eating
this insect
for example right right yeah interesting
so um we're
we're running a little short on time um
but i did want to mention
you you well you already mentioned and
you showed us a little bit about your
upcoming blog post um i know you you
have
all kinds of stuff out on community uh
and you did the
the marmorated stinkbugs blog post which
was uh
in itself a pretty interesting
exploration so if anyone
gets a chance that's watching right now
um you can check out the wolfram blog
there's
some additional content there um
but aside from that uh anybody at home
feel free to check out these functions
that joffrey's put together check out
the wolfram function repository
do some computation uh we'd love to hear
some more from
any citizen scientists out there or
researchers or anybody who's interested
in
getting into this biodiversity data so
thanks a lot for talking to me joffrey
thank you thanks for joining us
you can check out other wolfram tech
talks live coding streams and more
on the wolfram research youtube channel
or see what else is new at wolfram.com